so she has sympathy for him it sounds
like an okay and it's interesting that a
government Minister and someone close to
Rishi sunak is saying things like my
support is on pause this is a horrible
experience that Daisy Goodwin the TV
producer who says that she met Daniel
corski who now wants to be the London
mayor in Downing Street when he worked
there 10 years ago and claims that he
grouped her breast at the end of that
meeting and she's raising it now because
the metoo movement has made her realize
that you have to call these things out
he of course is categorically denied it
now what's going to happen as a result
well Daisy Goodwin has posted a picture
of an email she sent the cabinet office
now they would investigate allegations
against anyone working for the
government but I understand that they
don't routinely investigate people who
work for the government 10 years ago so
not although she has contacted them not
at all clear that they're going to pick
up the Baton of looking into this and as
for the conservative party he of course
wants to be the Conservative candidate
for mayor of London they've said they'll
investigate if a complaint is made to
them we don't know if she has made one
to them or not unless there is another
Authority like the government for
example who is looking into it too so I
think this raises the question this
morning of whether the conservative
party and the government are going to
back this between them and no one's
going to take responsibility because we
don't know at this current stage who
might look into this complaint but
Daniel corski as Camp campaign carries
on and he's tweeted this morning about
green energy there we go let's wait and
see what happens Stacey Goodwin making a
formal complaint to the government in
the form of the cabinet office about a
would be mayoral candidate for the
conservatives for the next uh next
election which is next year